Let's look at the answer for
our hit time quiz.
In a well-designed cache, hit time is
significantly lower than miss time.
Miss time includes the hit time and
the miss penalty.
Typically, we want the hit
time to be very small and
that means that the miss time should
not be anywhere close to the hit time.
And if there is any miss penalty,
miss time will be larger
than hit time anyway.
So this should be true for every cache,
even if you didn't design it very well.
Hit time is larger than the miss
penalty, we definitely don't want that.
The miss penalty is the memory access
time, if our hit time is similar to that
or larger than that, then the cache
is not going to be useful at all.
So this should not be selected.
Hit time equals to the miss penalty.
No, we want the hit time
to be significantly
less than the miss penalty.
If it is equal to the miss penalty,
we might just as well
go to memory every time, because
that's what the miss penalty is about.
So we should not sell like this.
And finally,
miss time larger than the miss penalty.
Miss time is equal to the hit
time plus the miss penalty, which
means that the miss time should always
be larger then the miss penalty anyway.
So this is true for every cache
not only a well designed one.
As we can see, for
a cache to be beneficial,
it needs to have a low hit time.
In fact, in a well designed cache,
we can say that the hit time is much
less than miss time
while the miss time and
miss penalty should be similar to each
other, because the hit time is so
small and the difference between
the two is the hit time.